se cacher en attendant la fin des
bombardements dont ce passage souterrain
de Kiev la scène est devenue quotidienne
presque banale un abri bienvenue face à
la reprise des raids aériens menées par
les forces russes selon les règles de
l'entreprise pour laquelle je travaille
il faut descendre par sécurité et nous
sommes ici depuis environ 3 heures en
perte de vitesse sur le terrain
militaire l'état-major russible des
infrastructures stratégiques à
l'approche de l'hiver avec ses outils
ces droneshad d'origine iranienne dont
des débris figures sur ces images des
armes légères peu coûteuses et
programmées pour atteindre un objectif
défini à l'avance mais que l'armée
ukrainienne parvient régulièrement à
intercepter selon le président elenski
nous avons des résultats significatifs
233 drones iraniens des dizaines de
missiles ont été abattus depuis un mois
Diderot iraniens ont été détruits
aujourd'hui rien que dans la région de
Kiev
une affirmation qui mettait rend sous
pression à la sortie d'une réunion
extraordinaire du Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU l'ambassadeur de la République
islamique a démenti ses accusations il a
un
catégoriement les allégations infondées
selon lesquelles l'Iran aurait transféré
des drones pour les utiliser dans le
cadre du conflit en Ukraine
à Kiev la rupture des relations
diplomatiques avec l'Iran et à l'étude
l'Union européenne qui dit avoir des
preuves de l'utilisation d'armes
iranienne en Ukraine prépare une
batterie de sanctions dont le contenu
sera révélé avant la fin de la semaine